Mayotte: After developing a wonderful application,
Testing and subtraction,
The next biggest challenge
How to increase a valuable audience of interested users.
Hi, I'm Frederic from the Google Play team.
Using the new tools in the Google Play Developer Console,
We facilitate the understanding of performance
User acquisition channels,
We help build new users
Across Google networks.
Imagine that you have developed a racing game called "RPM".
And impressed the experimental testers,
So I decided to put them on the public on Google Play.
Once users have started downloading your app,
You started asking yourself important questions.
"Where did the users come from?
"How did they hear about the game?
"What prompted them to install?
"And which of these users will be conducted
An in-app purchase most likely? "
You can now find answers to these questions
In the User Acquisition Performance report
In the Google Play Developer Console.
Summarizes the new user acquisition performance report
How users discover your app and how to spend their money.
You can see how many users have visited your store listing page,
And established the application,
They made one or more purchases at the end.
After seeing this information about the user's purchase,
You can choose some aspects to improve them
Or planning the store data list experiments
To explore different options.
For free discovery channels,
We show the number of visits coming from the Play Store
Outside,
Such as visits from users who have discovered your app via Google Search.
For visits from paid sources,
We identify individual Google AdWords campaigns
That are created directly from the Play Developer Console
Any other channels are tracked
Sending traffic to the store listing page.
By knowing which channels drive users to make purchases,
You can determine how to customize your marketing budget
So that the best return is achieved.
If marketers use Urchin traffic control tags on links,
The performance report will also track these marks
It will tell you specifically
Perform each channel of your channels.
Now that you know where users come from,
You want to start acquiring new users,
This is vital to your success.
There are several ways to acquire new users.
A common method is to pay for app install ads.
Where new global app campaigns are being used in that way.
It's the easiest way to promote your Android app
For interested users across Google Play,
Google Search, YouTube, and the Google Display Network.
You can do this now and directly from the Developer Console.
It takes a few clicks to start a campaign
Within your budget.
Let us see how this is done in practice.
When you open the Developer Console,
Go to your game and select the Acquisition tab.
From there, choose Create a new campaign.
The application creation form is already populated
Using existing Play Store listing assets,
Such as application code and short description
And the promotional video.
You can edit promotions a little if you want.
Only the maximum budget is left
And how much you want to pay for installing the app.
If you publish your game globally,
You will know that the investment in each market is different.
For example, the cost per installation may vary
Between the United States and Spain.
We recommend exploring
Logical cost per install
In each country you target on Google Play
You must also think about how much you will gain
Of the average user in each country.
It is important to experience the cost per install
To see how it affects the number of conversions
That are generated through your campaign.
After completing the form, you have completed everything.
The first RPM application promotion campaign is ready to launch.
Google Play will launch a fully automated campaign
Across Google networks.
Which includes web search from Google.com,
And AdMob on banner ads and mobile apps in the Google Display Network,
YouTube video ad placements,
And even search ads in the Play Store itself.
We do a hard job of knowing
The most appropriate ad placement for your app
And users who should be targeted.
Instant optimization is right for you.
That's why we call these campaigns 'global app campaigns'.
It's the fastest way
To start advertising your app with Google.
Using the performance report,
Understand and improve your acquisition channels,
Whether free or paid.
Using global application campaigns,
You'll be able to find users interested in your app
in no time.
Then, you should see the video we offer
About the Store Data Store Experiments.
You will learn how to perform the A / B test
On the Play Store data list and increase your installs.
This can compound the effect
All efforts are gained by users.
Thank you very much for watching.
[Happy music]